hi I'm Eric Voss and the movie Logan
made news recently for being the first
film of 2017 to send out Oscar screeners
now screeners are the DVDs that movie
studios sent out to promote a film as
being worthy of being nominated for an
Academy Award
normally this process happens later in
the fall every year but 20th Century Fox
wanted to get a head start and get Logan
and voters minds so this brings up one
of the biggest questions we've had in
2017 could Logan win an Oscar will it be
the first superhero movie to win Best
Picture in the past the superhero film
genre has been notoriously shut out from
the Oscar race many have gotten
nominated for technical awards like
visual effects but only a small number
of DC Marvel adaptations have actually
won the original Richard Donner Superman
won for visual effects Tim Burton's 1989
Batman won for art direction spider-man
2 won for visual effects The Dark Knight
won for Best Supporting Actor and for
sound editing and believe it or not
Suicide Squad won remember for makeup
and hairstyling which I guess makes
sense now of course many critics felt
the Dark Knight deserved to be nominated
for Best Picture and arguably it was its
snub that was the reason the Academy
switched to nominating up to 10 films
the following year now a big reason for
this trend is winning Oscars just isn't
what superhero movies typically aim to
do Studios like Marvel and Warner
Brothers and Fox really just wanted to
adapt comic book figures into
commercially successful films and
franchises studios see them as a way to
make money and often that comes at odds
with winning over 5,000 or so retirees
in LA who see a Marvel movies huge
financial profits as enough of a reward
and instead prefer to nominate a film
they see as more artistically
sophisticated and if what I just said
sounds super technical and political
that's because that's what the Oscars
are Academy voters don't reward the
truly best picture of the year they
reward whatever film they feel in that
year reflects on their moral conscience
but here's why some people think Logan
could break through all that it has a
few key strengths that you tend to see
in past oscar-nominated films for one
it's r-rated all of the recent Best
Picture winners have been r-rated and
allows films to explore more adult
themes and film goers tend to take them
more seriously also it stars Hugh
Jackman and Patrick Stewart in meaty
challenging roles and both actors are
considered Hollywood darlings whom the
Academy would presume
love to reward jackman even hosted the
Oscars in 2009 then Logan was also
directed by James Mangold's he's a heavy
hitter who's well regarded by Academy
voters from his work on the
award-winning walk the line and yeah
it's a really good film
it's a powerful redemption tale that
doesn't require a fanboys obsession with
comic-book mythology to appreciate it
however despite all those strengths I
don't think those will be enough to
guarantee Logan an Oscar nomination
instead I think there's one other key
element about this movie that gives it a
major edge Logan transforms its genre so
when Logan came out earlier this year a
lot of reviews were pointing out the
movies parallels with the classic
western Shane Shane even gets referenced
in the movie itself but there's another
famous Western that I think is an even
closer spiritual ancestor Unforgiven the
film starring and directed by Clint
Eastwood I rewatched it recently and
it's incredible and one of the things
Unforgiven did so well was it
deconstructed the tropes and stereotypes
of the western genre and used them to
tell a more grounded human story that
defied those traditions Eastwood plays
William Munny a washed-up former
gunslinger trying to escape his violent
past and these sensational tales that
people tell about him but he gets sucked
into a bloody conflict where he reverts
back into the animal people expect him
to be in Unforgiven killing isn't a fun
spectacle it's agonizing for the victim
and traumatic for the killer no one in
the film is a clear-cut good guy it's a
hell of a thing killing a man take away
all he's got and all he's ever gonna
this was a huge departure from every
previous Western movies actually that
made Clint Eastwood a star those all had
clear white hats and black hats and wild
shootouts with countless nobody's dying
without a second buy and it was largely
for this reason that many believe the
Academy went so apeshit for Unforgiven
they awarded at four Oscars Best Picture
Best Director Best Supporting Actor and
best editing to the voters Unforgiven
was transformative
Eastwood deconstructed the popularity of
his homes onra to produce something
deeper and more meaningful and one might
argue artistically redeem any
unsophisticated critics saw in the
western genre Unforgiven was the hero
a broader Hollywood narrative now the
same could be argued for Logan like
William Munny Logan is a washed-up
superhero trying to escape his violent
past who scoffs at the fish stories
people tell about him we got ourselves
an x-men fan maybe a quarter of it
happened and look at this in the real
world people die Hugh Jackman is two
superhero movies what Clint Eastwood was
to Western as Wolverine in the first
x-men in 2000 he was the guy who started
it all the guy who made the genre
popular and liked Eastwood and
Unforgiven Jackman uses Logan to ask
what it means to be a superhero to have
real blood on your hands and to carry
the emotional weight that any real human
would feel if they actually lived
through the bloodshed that these Marvel
and DC characters experienced all the
time
Logan is a richly human response to and
reflection on the superhero genre as a
whole the movies had have dominated the
film industry for the past decade it's a
movie about movies about the stories we
tell and our responsibility to tell them
right and unforgiven showed that that is
exactly the kind of film that film
critics and Oscar voters tend to embrace
when award season comes around
now of course Logan isn't the only good
film to come out in 2017 it's gonna be
tough to stand out in a crowded field of
films like Chris Nolan's Dunkirk which
used an inventive structure to document
a critical moment in history and Jordan
peels get out which was an amazing
horror film about racial tensions
not to mention Steven Spielberg's
upcoming the post starring Tom Hanks and
Meryl Streep as Nixon era Washington
Post editors I'm just saying don't be
surprised if politics plays a big role
in the Oscars next year I just hope
Logan can stay part of the conversation
maybe at least to recognize Jackman or
Stewart for their incredible
performances like I don't need superhero
movies to win Oscars
I'm just happy they exist at all and
they're enjoyable for the most part but
it would be nice for a film that rises
above the genre to be recognized for its
artistic achievement but I'm gonna throw
it to you
what other superhero movies do you think
deserved a Best Picture nomination
obviously the Dark Knight has been part
of that conversation forever but there's
also a lot of buzz around Wonder Woman
from this year and guys let's be honest
Howard the Duck Maj snug this your
favorites in the comments below or by
tweeting me at da boss or follow new
rockstars on twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos and share this
video
and subscribe to our channel for more
deep dives and the movies you love Andy
going to help us make more videos like
this you can contribute to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our current donors
especially Kristina Armstrong alright
thanks for watching bite